[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بابرز العناوين
الاسد يتراس وفد سوريا لحضور قمه الجامعه
العربيه بجده لاول مره منذ اندلاع الازمه
في بلاده
روسيا تشن هجوما مضادا على هجوم اوكرانيا
المضاد وامريكا تبحث تجميد الصراع على
الطريقه الكوريه
خروج مسيره الاعلام في القدس بحضور بن
خفيره ورئاسه الفلسطينيه تحذر من زياده
التوتر
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
هنري كسنجر يؤكد ان الحرب العالميه
الثالثه حتميه خلال عشر سنوات
ويسدي نصائح لتجنبها
[موسيقى]
وصل الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الى مدينه
جده للمشاركه في اعمال الدوره الثانيه
والثلاثين الاجتماع مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه على مستوى القمه وكان الاسد اكد
ان انعقاد القمه العربيه في السعوديه
سيعزز العمل العربيه المشترك لتحقيق
تطلعات الشعوب العربيه وبدا صباح اليوم
توافد زعماء دول العربيه الى جده للمشاركه
بالقمه
[موسيقى]
هذا وقلم عون وزير الخارجي السوري ايمن
سوسان في مقابله مع العربيه ان سوريا لم
تغب عن الجامعه العربيه بل ان التحديات
والظروف هي من فرضت عليها الغياب
هي لم تغب عن الجامعه العربيه او عن العرب
لتعود اليهم سوريا حاره دائما وكلمات جميع
من
الوفود العربيه بالامس تحدثت عن هذا
الحضور الدائم لسوريا في الوجدان العربيه
هناك ظروف
فرضت هذا الشيء
ربما يكون علينا جميعا
اما العوده
لا اعتقد ان المصطلح هو صحيح المهم اليوم
نحن مع بعض هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي علينا
كعرب ان نكون مع بعض لان في ذلك الخلاص
لنا ما شهدته دولنا خلال 12 سنه الماضيه
يثبت هذا الشيء الشرور التي احاطت ببعض
الدول العربيه انعكست على الجميع وبالتالي
انعكست على الواقع العربي كان الواقع
العربي غير صار فاصبح واقعا ماسويا
[موسيقى]
عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه بعد اكثر
من عقد على تجميد العضويه اعاد الى
الذاكره محطات تاريخيه خلال العقود
الثمانيه الماضيه منذ تاسيس الجامعه
بين اولى خطوات التاسيس لجامعه الدول
العربيه وعوده سوريا اليها بعد تجميد طويل
للعضويه ثمانيه عقود مرت فيها سوريا بتقلب
العلاقات مع الجامعه
تاريخيا سوريا كانت من اوائل الدول التي
شاركت بتمثيل قوي في الجامعه العربيه بعد
دعوه مصطفى النحاس رئيس الوزراء المصري
لنظيره السوري جميل مردنبك الى القاهره
لمناقشه انشاء تحالف عربي عام
1944 وتكون سوريا ضمن الدول السبع الموقعه
البروتوكول الاسكندريه
تزامنت قمه الجامعه عام
1967 في الخرطوم وحربي يونيو حيث خسرت
سوريا مناطق ابرزها الجولان في الحرب مع
اسرائيل وسميت بقمه اللات ثلاث لا صلح لا
تفاوض ولا اعتراف باسرائيل شاركت فيها
كافه الدول العربيه باستثناء سوريا التي
دعت الى حرب تحرير شعبيه
بيان ختامي صدر عن القمه العربيه في
نوفمبر
1973 في الجزائر التي انعقدت بمبادره
سوريه مصريه يقضي بتقديم الدعم المالي
والعسكري لسوريا ومصر بعد شنهما حرب
اكتوبر على اسرائيل لاسترداد الاراضي التي
خسيرتها في حرب 1967
قمه مايو 1990 في بغداد غابت عنها سوريا
اثر الخلافات السياسيه بين دمشق وبغداد
لكنها عادت للحضور الى القمه الطارئه في
اغسطس من نفس العام في القاهره على خلفيه
غزو العراق للكويت لتدين الحرب وتتضامن مع
الدول الخليج في المطالبه باخراج القوات
العراقيه من الكويت
اما اخر القمم التي برز فيها اسم سوريا
كانت في نوفمبر 2011 بعد ان اجمع القاده
العرب على تجميد عضويه دمشق على خلفيه رد
فعلها على الحراك الشعبي في البلاد اذا
عمر العربيه
وعلى هامش القمه عقد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع نظيره
العراقي فؤاد حسين عقد الاجتماع الرابع
للجنه السياسيه والامنيه والعسكريه
المنبثقه عن مجلس التنسيق السعودي العراقي
وذلك على هامش الاجتماعات التحضيريه
لوزراء الخارجيه العرب في جده وجاره خلال
الاجتماع استعراض سبل تطوير علاقات
البلدين بالاضافه الى التنسيق المشتركي في
المجالات السياسيه والامنيه والعسكريه
[موسيقى]
قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هانا
مليار ان روسيا تشن هجوما في باخموتا
واضافت ان القوات الاوكرانيه اصدت الهجمات
التي شنها الجيش الروسي على مدى يوم كامل
في المدينه المحاصره مضيفه الناموسكو جمعت
معظم قواتها في اتجاه بخموت واستقدمت
تعزيزات بشكل كبير
يقوم العدو باستطلاع جوي يوميا ونحن
بالطبع نعمل لمحاوله اكتشافهم وتدمير
طائراتهم
عندما نبدا في التقدم تقوم القوات الروسيه
بقصف جميع الطرق المؤديه الى المواقع
الاماميه حتى لا تتمكن مركباتنا المدرعه
من ايصال المزيد من المشاه والذخيره
واشياء اخرى
مهمتنا هي عزل مركباتهم الجويه غير
الماهوله حتى لا يروا سوى القليل من
حركاتنا وافعالنا وعندما تصعب عليهم
رؤيتنا سيكون هذا امتيازا لنا
خطه امريكيه لتجميد الصراع في اوكرانيا مع
اقرار بان لاختراق عسكريا قد يحدث والحل
هو وقف اطلاق النار دون حل هذا ما كشفت
عنه صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه تنقل
الصحيفه عن مصادر استخباراتيه متعدده
وايضا مسؤولين في البيت الابيض قولهم ان
امريكا الان خطه لتجميد الصراع تشبه تلك
التي حدثت خلال الحرب في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه بين الشماليه والجنوبيه حتى الان
لم يتم اعلان انهاء حاله الحرب بين
الكوريتين ولكن تلتزم الدولتان بخط لوقف
اطلاق النار مع تكديس القدرات العسكريه
على جانبي شبه الجزيره فما هي اسباب هذه
الخطه الامريكيه حسب مسؤولين امريكيين فلن
تعترف موسكو او كياف بالهزيمه على الاطلاق
كما ان الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني لن يوجه
ضربه قاتله لروسيا في الاثناء ترتفع
فاتوره دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا على امريكا
وهو ما يسبب ازمه داخل امريكا خصوصا مع
ضغط الجمهوريين لخفض هذه التكلفه
[موسيقى]
استراتيجيه تجميد الصراع حسب المسؤولين
الامريكيين ليبوليتيكو بدا تنفيذها بالفعل
ويظهر ذلك في الاسلحه التي يتم تقديمها
ليكياف فالان اتجهت امريكا الى توفير
الدعم لاوكرانيا عبر طلب معدات عسكريه من
المصانع وبدات في التوقف عن امدادها
باسلحه جاهزه بالفعل وموجوده في مخازن
الجيش ما يعني ان حصول اوكرانيا على
الاسلحه ستصبح عمليه ممتده على مدى سنوات
مثال على ذلك امريكا قررت مؤخرا ان تخصص
لاوكرانيا مليارا و 200 مليار دولار
لتصنيع اسلحه جديده وذلك بدلا من ان
تمنحها اسلحه مباشره من مخزونها وعمليه
التصنيع هذه ستستغرق سنوات ومع دخول الحرب
مرحله التجميد ستتحول الى صراع استنزاف لا
يكسب اي من الجانبين الكثيره على الارض مع
عمليات نوعيه متفرقه تماما كما حدث في
دومباس منذ عام 2014 وحتى انطلاق الحرب
الاخيره في 2022 الى ذلك ردت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه على هذا التقرير وقالت ان
تجميد الصراع سيجعل العالم يعيش في ابتزاز
نووي على اساس يومي وايضا خطر حدوث ازمه
غذاء
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه في
ارغانم اهلا بك معنا في هذه النشره اذا
حسب بوليتيكو هناك اتجاه امريكي لتجميد
الصراع الاوكراني ما المواقف الامريكيه
الرسميه الداله على هذا الاتجاه وكيف
سيحصل
الملكين يريدون تجميد الصراع هناك ضغطه
اخرى مهمه يجب ان نقول انه على المدى
المتوسط ونتحدث هنا ليس عن سنه او سنتين
عن خمس سنوات او ست سنوات فان هناك مشروع
ضخم امريكي واطلسي ايضا باعاده تصليح
اوكرانيا بمعدات اطلسيه وليس ان تكتفي
اوكرانيا بان يكون لديها سلاح من هندسه
روسيه او من تصنيع روسي العنصر ثالث المهم
جدا هو ان الامريكيين يحاولون فهم الخريطه
الدوليه وما يشغل بل هم بشكل خاص هو
التقارب الصيني الروسي بسبب موضوع
اوكرانيا وهذا ما يعمل عليه على امريكيون
في هذه الخريطه
الامريكيين ايضا يرزحون تحت وطاه الضرائب
وارتفاع الاسعار والتضخم وايضا الحكومه
الامريكيه تحد ضغط الجمهوريين لخفض هذه
التكلفه تكلفه هذه الحرب على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كيف تتعامل الحكومه
وبايدن مع كل ذلك كيف سيتعاملون مع ذلك
الرئيس الامريكي خلال الاشهر الماضيه وتحت
ضغوطات من بعض الجمهوريين بعدم تسليح
اوكرانيا او عدم اعطاء شك مفتوح
للاوكرانيين تابع ارسال المليارات من
الاسلحه الى الاوكرانيين ولم يتاثر بهذه
الضغوطات من الضروري ايضا القول ان زعماء
الجمهوريين يريدون من الرئيس الامريكي ان
يزيد من هذه المساعدات الى اوكرانيا
المطلب الوحيد عند الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين ايضا هو ان يكون هناك اشراف
اكثر على عمليه الصرف ولا ان يكون شك
مفتوح في كل الاوقات ويجب ان نقول الى ان
بعض الاشخاص الذين يمارسون بعض الضغوطات
على الاداره الامريكيه وهو هم نواب من
الجمهوريين الذين اختفى صوتهم خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المعلومات بار غانم مراسل العربيه من
[موسيقى]
شارك عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين في
مسيره الاعلام التي تنظم كل سنه في ذكرى
احتلال القدس الشرقيه وشارك وزير الامن
القومي اليمني اتمار بن خفير ووزير
الماليه اليمينيس موتيريتش في المسيره
وحضرت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه من اصرار
اسرائيل على تنظيم المسيره الاستفزازيه
مشيره الى ان ذلك يؤكد موافقه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على اراء المتطرفين الامر
الذي سيؤدي لمزيد من التوتر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حضر ممثل منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه
للامم المتحده في السودان ادم يوم من خطر
مجاعه في البلاد اذا لم يتم دعم المنظمات
الانسانيه وتسير عملها وتوفير الموارد
اللازمه للمزارعين وقال انه في حال تعذر
وصول المزارعين الى حولهم خلال شهري يونيو
ويوليو المقبلين لزراعه محاصيل رئيسيه
سيصبح الامن الغذائي لملايين السودانيين
مهددا واكد ان اسعار الغذاء في السودان قد
ترتفع بشكل غير مسبوق خلال الاشهر المقبله
اذا استمر القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع محذرا من ان استمرار القتال قد
يترتب عليه انهيار موسم الزراعه الحالي
وننتقل لنستمع الى وقائع جلسه مجلس الامن
بشان الملف الاوكراني وكذلك السرايا
الاوكرانيه المختلفه ان الهدف الذي
يحدوا الغرب جد واضح وهم لا يحاولون اخفاء
ذلك وهذا بعيد جدا البعد من المبادئ
الانسانيه هم يستخدمون اوكرانيا كارض
للاختبار لاجراء اختبارات وذلك لجرنا
جميعا الى نزاع لانهاء
حتى اخر اوكرانيه وذلك ايضا لاحداث هزيمه
استراتيجيه بروسيا وفي القلب من ذلك تمت
ثلاث نقاط جد واضحه الا وهي رغبه فيما
يطلق عليه نظام
العالميه القائم على القواعد الوفي ديسمبر
الماضي اعتمد الكونجرس الامريكيه 48 مليار
دولار بقيمه مساعده عسكريه لاوكرانيا
وشريحه واعلن عن شريحه جديده بمقدار 1.2
مليار دولار
منذ قريب جوسيب بوريل ايضا اعلن عن اجمالي
المساعدات التي تقدم الكلاب التي تصل الى
16 مليار يورو وكذلك هذا بوريل نفسه وعينه
قد اقترح ان يخصص 3.5 مليار يورو كمساعدات
ماليه اضافيه في صندوق السلام الاوروبي
وتوجه الى اوكرانيا ولقد ان الاوان لكي
نسمي الاشياء بمسمياتها ولكي نعيد تسميه
هذا الصندوق صندوق الحرب الاوروبيه كما ان
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تخطط لتخصيص اكثر من
1.5 مليار يورو للاذخائر هذا بالاضافه الى
ما اعلنت عنه المانيا من ارسال كميه كبيره
مما يطلق عليه
مساعدات بقيمه 2.7 مليار يورو هذه
المساعدات تاتي في شكل دبابات هذا
بالاضافه الى المدفعيه
المضاده للطائرات ومئات القذائف الموجهه
وكذلك
الطائرات الاستطلاعيه والمركبات الدعم
اللوجستيه علاوه على ذلك وبشكل عام
واجمالي من الدول الاعضاء في الناتو وكما
اشار الامين العام
للمنظمه ينسى
قد خصص اكثر من 65 مليار يورو لاحتياجات
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وايضا نجد ان
هذه
الاسلحه تصل بشكل متسع ولقد
قيل ان اكثر من 600 دبابه قد ارسلت الى
اوكرانيا هذا بالاضافه الى نقاشات الدائره
فيما يتعلق بارسال طائرات مقاتله وكذلك في
اوروبا
ففي المانيا يجري تدريب للقوات الخاصه في
الحقيقه ان اوكرانيا تستخدم من جانب الغرب
كارض كارض اختبارات
وكارض للتجارب ولا يابهون ابدا بمصيري
شعبي اوكرانيا ولا يابهون حتى
بالمغضب الوحشيه التي يمكن ان يتكشمها
الشعب الاوكرانيه
ونجد ان الصرب على سبيل المثال قد قصفته
من قوات النيتو في عام 1999
من اليورانيوم
المنضب
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه المندوب
الروسي الدائم في مجلس الامن الوزيري
نابلسيا وتتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
امريكا واليابان تؤكدان ان العالم يعيش
اعقد بيئه امنيه في التاريخ الحديث واكسف
يحذر من الاقتراب من الحرب العالميه
الثالثه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان العالم ما يواجه واحده من اعقد
البيئات الامنيه في التاريخ الحديث واضاف
بايدن خلال لقائه برئيس وزراء اليابان في
هيروشيما قبل انعقاد قمه مجموعه السبع ان
التعاون مع اليابان ضروريون من اجل ان
يصبح العالم اكثر امنا ومن المقرر ان
يناقش قاده مجموعه السبع الحربه في
اوكرانيا اضافه الى استراتيجيه في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ لتصدي لنفوذ
الصين حسب مسؤولين امريكيين
تجنب العالم الدخول في حرب عالميه ثالثه
يعتمد على الولايات المتحده والصين بحسب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الاسبق هنري
كاسنجر خبير الدبلوماسيه الذي سيكمل بعد
ايام عامه المئه قال ان مصير البشريه
سيعتمد على امكانيه تعايش امريكا والصين
مشيرا الى ان التقدم السريع للذكاء
الاصطناعي لن يترك لهما سوى عشر سنوات
لايجاد طريق والا فهي الحرب اذا عشر سنوات
ابدى كاسينجر قلقه من ان كلا الجانبين
اقنعا نفسيهما بان الاخر يمثل خطرا
استراتيجيا ما سيقود الى مواجهه بين
القوتين العظيمتين وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الاسبق اعتبر ان الوضع حاليا يشبه ما قبل
الحرب العالميه الاولى مع تعنت الجانبين
وعدم وجود هامش للمناوره السياسيه بينهما
ما قد يؤدي فعلا للتراب عالمي كيسينجر
اضاف في لقائ مع مجله الى ان الخوف من
الحرب سيخلق ارضيه للامل الا ان المعضله
تكمن في ان الطرفين ليس لديهما مساحه
كبيره لتقديم تنازلات يعتمد طريق سنجر
للخروج من هذا المازق على خفض التصعيد بين
البلدين اولا ومن ثم بناء الثقه وعلاقه
العمل تدريجيا وصولا الى ضبط نفس بشكل
مستمر
هي دعوه هندي كسنجر للولايات المتحده
مشيرا الى ان الدول يجب ان تعمل بسياسه
خارجيه تستند الى تحالفات غير دائمه موجهه
نحو القضايا بدلا من ربط الدوله في
تحالفات كبيره متعدده الاطراف
الدبلوماسيه السابق قال ان الولايات
المتحده بحاجه ماسه الى التفكير
الاستراتيجي طويل المدى ودعم انشاء نظام
عالمي على اساس القواعد التي يمكن لاوروبا
والصين والهند الانضمام
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه الدكتور وليد
فارس اهلا بك معنا السيد وليد اذا الحرب
الصينيه الامريكيه المؤجله هل فعلا هي
محتومه وتوافق كسنجر الراي وان حصلت ما هي
ساحاتها
والسيناريو المتوقع
مذكرات اسم جنيرى يقرا التاريخ في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه
هو بالطبع اختبر كل هذه النظريات في كيفيه
حل الازمات والمواجهات او حتميه وقوع
الحروب ابان الحرب البارده ابان الحرب
البارده كانت هنالك انظمه لن تمانع
بمواجهات حتى على الصعيد النووي ولكن قيلت
كل الحرب البارده هذا لم يحدث ماذا يعني
يعني انه هو ينظر الى السيناريوهات الاسود
انه اذا لم تغير امريكا والصين سياساتها
فحتما اوتوماتيكيا يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي
لو كان موجودا لوقت البارده كان يمكن ان
يفجر هذه الحرب عنده نقاط كثيره له حق
كبير فيها وعنده بعض النقاط ربما يجب
النظر من منظار اخر عليها من النقاط
الحقيقيه هي انه السياسه الخارجيه حاليا
لا تضبط الامن العالمي مع مع فرقه يعني
منذ حرب اوكرانيا لا يخفى على احد انقسم
مجلس الامن الدولي كانت هنالك عقوبات لم
نشهدها من السابق وطبعا هنالك محليه من في
اوكرانيا وفي اماكن اخرى الان في السودان
كل ذلك ينظر بالاسوا ولكن السؤال الكبير
هل هذه الاطراف الان وقد دخلت عالم ما بعد
الحرب البارده وما بعد حتى المراحل
الحديثه يعني
هل هي مستعده فعلا لمواجهه هل تدفع الثمن
لمواجهه نوويه
وتدمر كل ما قد جنته بالاربعه او خمس عقود
ماضيه هذا امر لا يمكن الرد عليه ولكن هذا
امر يفتح تساؤلات كثيره
يقول بانه ليس لدى الصين او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه القدره على تقديم اي
تنازلات هل توافقه الراي يعني ان تتحدثت
الان عن مكان او ربما اخطاء بالسياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه الا يمكن اصلاحها
في اخطاء في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
دون شكوى انا من اكبر المنتقدين تحت كل
الادارات وكتبت في هذا الاتجاه ولكن
الاطراف الاخرى يعني ليست ملائكه كما يقال
فهي هي هي لها سياسات شامله توسعيه لما
هنالك الاخطاء في السياسه الامريكيه حسب
اي اداره هو القيام بكثير من التنازلات في
وقت لا يجب ان تقوم بالتنازلات واحيانا
قيام برداد فعل لا يجب القيام بها هذه
فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولكني اعود الى النقطه الاساسيه هنالك
اليه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحت
الاداره او اي اداره اخرى اعرف تماما انه
هنالك نقطه اللا عوده ما هي نقطه اللعوده
اعطاء امر بعمليه نوويه لانه الجميع يعرف
وهذا كان واضح ضمن حتى حقبت الحرب البارده
انه عندما تبدا بمواجهه نوويه لا تعرف كيف
الصين لم تكن كذلك في الخمسينات والستينات
والسبعينات كانت محكومه من قبل شيوعي حزب
شيوعي ومستعد لان يدخل في هكذا مواجهه
الصين تغيرت الثلاث عقود الماضيه اصبحت
دوله فعلا حزبها الذي يحكمها هو شيوعي
ولكن تصرفاتها برجوازيه هي راس ماليه
لديها كل ديون العالم تقريبا وتمتد في كل
القارات على الصعيد الاقتصادي هل تخاطر
الصين باي مواجهه من هذا النوع اقول نوويه
وحتى غير نوويه بما فيه تايوان
الاستفزاز الامريكي بالنسبه للصين
الصين ترى تحالف امريكا
هو استفزاز لها لانه هي تقول هذا هذا
البلد ليس مستقلا هذا لا ترضاه الاولاد
بعد الامريكيه انه ان ياتي طرف اخر ويقول
هذه الاسكا سنعيدها الى روسيا هنالك قانون
دولي القانون الدولي لا يمكن ان تاخذي
الاراضي بالقوه والا كانت هنالك يعني ردت
فعل وعقوبات كما حدث في موضوع اوكرانيا
وغيرها نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا الدكتور
وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
تحذير شديد اللهجه من طهران لحكومه طالبان
بسبب خلاف الدولتين على توزيع حصص المياه
بينهما الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي قال ان ايران
ستعمل اي وسيله اي متاحه للحصول على حقها
في المياه بعد اغلاق طالبان لسد كجكي في
الواقع هذا النهر واقع تحديدا على نهرها
المد على الحدود بين الدولتين على الجانب
الاخر تقول طالبان ان منع ايصال المياه
الى ايران سببه قله توفر المياه في نهرها
المند والجفاف وانعدام الامطار على
المناطق الغربيه لافغانستان يتمحور الخلاف
الايراني الافغاني بشان الماء اساسا حول
هذا النهد نهر الذي ينبع من جبال هندو كوش
شمال شرقي افغانستان ويصب في بحيره هامون
الايرانيه ويعد اهم موارد الماء في
البلدين في سنه 19
ابرمت الحكومتان الايرانيه والافغانيه
اتفاقيه اقتسام مياه هلمن وحددت حصه ايران
الثانويه ب 820 مليون متر مكعب من المياه
افغانستان 57 مليار متر مكعب من متوسط
الانهار السنوي ولكنها تستهلك اقل من ثلث
هذا الرقم ويذهب
الباقي من المياه الى دول الجوار مثل
باكستان وايران ودول اسيا الوسطى تقول
ايران انها خسرت العام الماضي اربعه
ملايين متر مكعب من المياه في حين تراجع
منسوب المياه في الانهار الافغانيه بسبب
الجفاف وايضا قله هطول الامطار وتطالب
طهران باعاده النظر في الاتفاقيه التي
وقعت بين البلدين لكن الحكومات الافغانيه
المتتاليه ترفض هذا الطلب الايراني وتقول
ان الاتفاقيه شامله وتنص على وضع المياه
طيله فصول السنه وتطالب طهران بالالتزام
بها
معاهديه وفقا للمعاهده هذا حق طبيعي
لايران واذا لزم الامر سنستخدم ادوات
الضغط الاجبار ذلك القسم من الهيئه
الحاكمه الافغانيه الذي لا يتعاون بشان
منح ايران حصتها المائيه من نهرها
انقاذه من منزله الذي تعرض للغرق لكن حظه
افضل من تسعه اشخاص اخرين قتلوا بسبب هذه
الفيضانات ورغم كل تلك المياه التي تحيط
بهم الا انه يواجه ازمه مياه شرب نظيفه
بسبب تضرر البنيه التحتيه خصوصا ان
الحكومه لم تكن تتوقع كارثه كتلك
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم لمدير الاتصالات في حكومه
رئيس وزراء بريطانيا الاسبق باريس جونسون
يقول الرجل ان جونسون خلال اجتماع للحكومه
قال انه سيالكم الرئيس الفرنسي اماني
المكروه في وجهه لانه متملق لبوتين واضاف
اند جونسون غاضبه من زياره
قبل بدء حرب اوكرانيا ووصف هذه الزياره
بالمقززه
اما فيديو اليوم فهو من العاصمه التركيه
انقره التي تعرضت لامطار غزيره وعواصف لكن
كان الحدث الابرز هو ما وفقه احد السكان
لاريكه الطائره بعد سقوطها من مبنى سكني
مكون من 35 سابقا الاريكه التي طارت بفعل
العواصف استقرت في النهايه في حديقه بعد
ان اصطدمت بمبان في طريقها
العربيه 360 مستمره معكم هذه الليله ولكن
مع الزميله رشا نبيل ومتابعه للقمه
العربيه المقرر انطلاقها غدا تفضل يا رشا
انت وضيوفك
[موسيقى]
مستمرون مع حضراتكم من مدينه جده السعوديه
حيث القمه العربيه المرتقبه غدا قمه عربيه
جديده تحمل عناوين جديده القمه تحمل عنوان
رئيسي وهو عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
ولكن هناك العديد من الاسئله الفرعيه
المرتبطه بهذا الامر بالاضافه الى قضايا
اخرى اما الاسئله الفرعيه فهي عادت سوريا
ولكن ماذا عن العلاقات العربيه السوريه مع
العديد من الدول عادت سوريا ولكن ماذا عن
الازمه السوريه ماذا عن قضايا اللاجئين
ماذا عن اعاده الاعمار ماذا عن التشابات
الاقليميه المرتبطه بهذه الازمه سواء فيما
يتعلق بالدور الايراني او الدور التركيه
اسئله كبيره وكثيره نحاول ان نرصد لها
المشهد
اكثر مما يدور في اذهان الجمهور العربي
بين اولى خطوات التاسيس لجامعه الدول
العربيه وعوده سوريا اليها بعد تجميد طويل
للعضويه ثمانيه عقود مرت فيها سوريا بتقلب
العلاقات مع الجامعه
تاريخيا سوريا كانت من اوائل الدول التي
شاركت بتمثيل قوي في الجامعه العربيه بعد
دعوه مصطفى النحاس رئيس الوزراء المصري
لنظيره السوري جميل مردنبك الى القاهره
لمناقشه انشاء تحالف عربي عام
1944 وتكون سوريا ضمن الدول السبع الموقعه
البروتوكول الاسكندريه
تزامنت قمه الجامعه عام
1967 في الخرطوم وحربي يونيو حيث خسرت
سوريا مناطق ابرزها الجولان في الحرب مع
اسرائيل وسميت بقمه اللات ثلاث لا صلح لا
تفاوض ولا اعتراف باسرائيل شاركت فيها
كافه الدول العربيه باستثناء سوريا التي
دعت الى حرب تحرير شعبيه
بيان ختامي صدر عن القمه العربيه في
نوفمبر
1973 في الجزائر التي انعقدت بمبادره
سوريه مصريه يقضي بتقديم الدعم المالي
والعسكري لسوريا ومصر بعد شنهما حرب
اكتوبر على اسرائيل لاسترداد الاراضي التي
خسرتها في حرب 1967
قمه مايو 1990 في بغداد غابت عنها سوريا
اثر الخلافات السياسيه بين دمشق وبغداد
لكنها عادت للحضور الى القمه الطارئه في
اغسطس من نفس العام في القاهره على خلفيه
غزو العراق للكويت لتدين الحرب وتتضامن مع
الدول الخليج في المطالبه باخراج القوات
العراقيه من الكويت
اما اخر القمم التي برز فيها اسم سوريا
كانت في نوفمبر 2011 بعد ان اجمع القاده
العرب على تجميد عضويه دمشق على خلفيه رد
فعلها على الحراك الشعبي في البلاد اذا
عمر العربيه
ونبقى معكم في هذه التغطيه الحيه
والمباشره على شاشه العربيه من مدينه جده
السعوديه حيث القمه العربيه المرتقبه غدا
هناك تساؤلات حول الملف السوري تحمل
عناوين عريضه ينضم الينا في هذا الجزء من
التغطيه معالي الوزير سميح المعايطه وزير
الاعلام الاردني الاسبق مرحبا معالي
الوزير مساء الخير واهلا ينضم الينا من
دمشق الكاتب الصحفي استاذ غسان يوسف مرحبا
بك استاذ غسان معنا على شاشه العربيه في
هذه التغطيه هناك محاور واسئله تتعلق
بسوريا كنت قد استعرضت جانبا منها في
المقدمه ولكن معالي الوزير بدايه لا يفهم
الجمهور العربي كثيرا ما هو المقصود بفكره
او قاعده خطوه مقابل خطوه عاد سوريا كخطوه
اذا ما هي الخطوه او الخطوات التاليه
لا هي عوده سوريا
زي ما بنحكي في ثلاث مسارات في العلاقات
الثنائيه بين سوريا ودول عربيه وهذه تمت
بقرارات ذاتيه من الدول اللي قعدت علاقتها
في العلاقه سوريا مع الجامعه العربيه وهذه
تمت خلال الاسبوع الماضي بقرار من وزراء
خارجيه الدول العربيه بتعليق انهاء تعليق
عضويه سوريا
اللي في اعاده سوريا الى المجتمع الدولي
الخطوات التي يجب على سوريا ان تقوم يقوم
بها العالم وتقوم بها لانه المشكله هذه
الخطوات يتعلق بحل الازمه السوريه يعني
عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه هي وحده
من ادوات المهمه لانه في فريق عربي تم
تجديد فريق عربي من عده الدول ليقوم
بالتواصل بين سوريا وبين الولايات المتحده
والاوروبيين لموضوع تفكيك عقد الازمه
السوريه من القضايا السياسيه قضايا
الانسانيه قضايا الى اخره في ملف اعاده
الاعمار في ملف طويل هذا الملف لا يمكن
للعرب ان يذهبوا الى سوريا ويقودوا تحرك
مع العالم وهم مقاطعين لسوريا يعني هذه
منطقه مش مقبول فعوده سوريا هي مهمه جدا
للسوريين او مهمه جدا للعرب اللي بتبنوا
من المبادره اللي هي مبادره اعاده سوريا
للحاله الدوليه واعاده تاهيل سوريا
ومساعده سوريا وهذا امر مهم بالمناسبه
مساعده سوريا على التخلص من اثار الازمه
والحرب التي كانت فيها ومساعده الدول التي
تضررت من الازمه وتحديدا في ملف اللاجئين
على بدء باعاده اللاجئين او فتح مسار
لاعاده اللاجئين والتخفيف على هذه الدول
من الاردن لبنان مثلا تركيا الى اخره من
هذه الدول فخطوه بخطوه ليست بين العرب
وبين السوريين بتقديري لانه هذه اليوم
مثلا في دول رغم عوده سوريا للجامعه
العربيه لن تعيد علاقاتها بسوريا لانه هذا
قرار الذاتي لكن سوريا يجب ان تكون
بيوتهم تدمرت بحكم الحرب في فش بني تحتيها
التعليم
فهذا بصير تنسيق مع هذا اللي ورد في بيان
عمان انه تنسيق مع الامم المتحده تتولى
الامم المتحده اخذ عينه من اللاجئين
بالاردن الف شخص لحظه وبرجعوهم على الامم
المتحده قبل ما يرجعوا بتقوم بتمويل
عمليات بناءه البيوت او ترميمها بناء بني
تحته لمجموعات صغيره يعني ما بنحتاج
للتريليون دولار حتى نعيد اعمار سوريا
بعدين نقول تعالوا فممكن تبدا انت بحالات
او بمجموعات من الدول وتفتح الطريق
للموضوع اثنين في مسارات لها علاقه
باللاجئين تتعلق بالقضايا السياسيه يعني
قضايا في ناس لهم ملفات مطلوبين للام
السوري هذه بده يتم معالجتها من قبل
السوريين
وهذه نقطه مهمه للغايه وحساسه ايضا
ويشاركنا في الحوار استاذ غسان يوسف استاذ
غسان هناك سؤال مطروح
عوده سوريا الى الجامعه هي عوده الى يعني
اذا ما يقال دائما الى البيت العربي ولكن
ماذا عن الازمه السوريه هناك شق متعلق
بالمعارضه هناك شق متعلق باثني عشر عاما
من الاقتتال الاف من القتلى والضحايا كيف
سيتم التعامل مع هذه القضايا الحساسه
للغايه
تحياتي
الوزير والمشاهدين الكرام طبعا يعني اعتقد
بان عوده سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه
هو يعني السبيل الصحيح بحل المشكله في
كوريا بالتعاون مع الدول العربيه وتعرفين
يعني بان الدول العربيه كانت منخرطه في
المسؤوليه منذ بدايتها في العمل
ولهذا تم تجديد عضويه سوريا اليوم سوريا
يعني لن تكون هي بعيده عن القرار الذي
يطلقك بحقها او بما يخص يعني شؤونها
الداخليه هي اليوم مشاركه في الاجتماعات
مشاركه في اتخاذ القرارات هي اليوم ستطرح
على الدول العربيه احتياجات سوريا كدوله
خارجه من الازمه وتعرفين يعني هناك ازمه
اللاجئين ازمه وصول مساعدات الانسانيه من
المعارض الشرعيه هناك عوده يعني
مثلا مكافحه الارهاب هناك الاحتلالات
الاجنبيه هناك ايضا قضيه المخدرات هناك
كثير من القضايا التي تريد سوريا مثلا ان
تطرحها على الدول العربيه واهم هذه
القضايا انا اعتقد بانها عوده اللاجئين
وايضا تشهيت منازع الارهاب ويعني هناك
مجموعات ارهابيه موجوده في سوريا يعني
اللي هي لحمايه مثلا الولايات المتحده
هناك لديك جيش سوريا الحره في المنطقه
الجنوبيه في المنطقه الشرقيه لديك مجموعات
ارهابيه مرتبطه مع الولايات المتحده ايضا
تعمل مع قاعده التنفس في في الشمال الغربي
معالي الوزير في هذا الامر لان هناك خلط
لدى الجميع في المسميات كل طرف يستخدم
تعبيرات تفضل تفضل
كنت اقول لك يعني حتى اليوم مثلا هناك ما
يسمى الجيش الوطني وهو مجموعه من
المجموعات المسلحه التي
ذهبت للقتال مثلا في ليبيا غير استخدمتها
حتى تبدا الدوله السوريه و ضد دول اخرى
لديك جبهه اخرى ولديك المقاتلين الاجانب
يعني هناك قرى كامله في ادلب هجر اهلها
وسكنها صينيون
وغيرهم انا اعتقد بان سوريا ستضع اليوم او
الاوراق كلها بشكل منفتح على الدول
العربيه وتقول لهم هذا هو حال سوريا اليوم
ويعني تعرفين بان الولايات المتحده تقوم
بتسديد العقوبات على سوريا يعني رشا كان
من يومين هناك مشروع قرار لتوسيع قانون
قيصر وتجديد قانون قيصر وايضا يعني
الاوروبيين من يومين جددوا العقوبات
الاوروبيه على سوريا لذلك اليوم انا اعتقد
بان القمه العربيه
ستضع اجنده للوقوف الى جانب الدوله
السوريه ومساعده سوريا لتخفض جميع هذه
المشكلات طبعا يعني كما قال وزير الخارجيه
الدكتور فيصل مقداد يعني سيكون هناك تعاون
تنفيذ سيكون هناك تضامن سيكون هناك نظره
الى المستقبل لا عوده الى الوراء ويعني
اعتقد بان هذا هو السبيل الصحيح لحل مشاكل
ولكن المشكله هنا وهذا ما كنت اطرحه على
حضرتك منذ قليل ويشاركنا ايضا معالي
الوزير في الامر هو الاختلاف في استخدام
المصطلحات والمسميات يعني هناك توصيف واضح
من قبل الحكومه السوريه ان هناك جماعات
ارهابيه الغرب والولايات المتحده لا ترى
انها جماعات ارهابيه بينما ترى انها
جماعات معارضه وبالتالي هذا يعود الى فكره
هل يمكن ان يكون هناك حوارا وطنيا داخليا
ما بين الحكومه وما بين المعارضه وماذا عن
القضايا الحساسه وشائكه المتعلقه بملف
الاكراد مثلا نحن امام معضلات صعبه للغايه
صحيح في ملفات صعبه كتير وفي ملفات جزء من
علاقات سوريا مع دول اخرى مثل ملف الاكراد
له علاقه بتركيا وسوريا بتعرفي كان في
يعني تقارب كبير بين تركيا وسوريا خلال
الفتره الماضيه الانتخابات التركيه اللي
كانت الاحد الماضي شوي وقفت الامور لكن
بعد 28 الشهر ايا كان من سياتي سواء
اردوغان او معارضه بالتاكيد ستشهد
العلاقات التركيه السوريه تسارع ملف
الكردي والتواجد الكردي في شمال سوريا
اللي هو مطلب للسوريين انسحاب القوات
التركيه من من الاراضي السوريه تعتقد وحده
من القضايا اللي راح تبحث وتكون يتم
الحديث فيها وبتعمق لانه في مصلحه للطرفين
هسا بهذا المساله في ادلب ادلب مثلا مكان
يحتوي تنظيمات ارهابيه ومتطرفه
عن حوار معها ولا عن عن شيء هذه بتعرف
مصنف كل كل العرب بيتعاملوا معها بهذا
بهذا الموضوع ملف الاكراد ملف الامريكان
ملف الاكراد له علاقه بامريكا لانه
الامريكان داعمين للجزء من الاكراد
والامريكان موجودين في مناطق كمان في شرق
سوريا عند النفط وعند
النفطان في ذات
لفكره التدخلات الاقليميه والدولي اتحدث
عن الولايات المتحده عن روسيا عن ايران عن
تركيا يعني
احنا لما بنحكي كل هاي التفصيلات بنحكي عن
ملف ليس من السهل الانتهاء منه قريبا هذا
ملف معقد لكن لا بد ان تبدا يعني لو لو لم
تبدا الدول العربيه بهذا الامر بدها تضل
الامور على حالها ففي دول تحركت بالموضوع
هسا التحرك الاساسي المفتاح الاساسي
بالقسط الامريكان الامريكان صحيح كان يعني
بعيدين في بعض المفاصل لكن لما كان جزء من
الازمه السوريه الامريكان هم اللي وضعوا
قانون قيصر للعقوبات على سوريا في
الاوروبيين عندهم كمان مواقف البرلمانات
الاوروبيه فبده يكون تحرك مع هذه الملفات
اليوم موضوع ايران بسوريا
موضوع الميليشيات اللي موجوده اللي اجت
خلال فتره الحرب في خليط من الاشياء روسيا
طرف مهم يعني البدايه اللي صار باجتماع
السعوديه ثم باجتماع عمان اجتماع عمان مهم
كان لانه وزير خارج السوري موجود يعني كل
ما صدر بالاجتماع في موافقه سوريه عليه
هذا امر المهم انه سوريا وافقت على ما ورد
بس هذا الشغل اللي بده ينحك ياخذ له سنه
سنتين ثلاثه اذا نحن امام محاوله عربيه
جاده للتصدي لهذا الملف بكل تفاصيله واضحه
للتعامل بالموضوع ومعتمده على التجاوب
السوري ومعتمده على حوار معمق مع
الاوروبيين والاميركان بالموضوع
واعود ايضا الى ضيفي استاذ غسان توفيق من
دمشق ولكن نستمع الى ما قاله الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه السيد احمد ابو
الغيط في حواره مع زميله منتهى الرمحي على
شاشه العربيه فيما يتعلق بعوده سوريا الى
النهارده سوريا
عضو كامل العضويه له كل الصلاحيات وكل
الحقوق وكل الواجبات على
الدوله العطر طبعا هذه العوده
لا تفرض على الدول اعضاء الجامعه نهجم
معين تجاه
الحكومه السوريه هي عاده
بتوافق من الجميع
هناك من سوف يعيد علاقات وهناك من سوف
يتحفظ في اعاده العلاقات هذا امر خاص
بزياده كل دوله لكن عضويتها كامله واعتقد
انها
سببت
غضب لدى اعداء الحكم في سوريا في العالم
الغربي اساسا
واعود مره اخرى لهذا الجزء من التغطيه
ومعي من دمشق استاذ غسان يوسف استاذ غسان
ربما ما شعرت به وانا اتحدث مع معالي
الوزير فيما يتعلق بالازمه السوريه اننا
امام طريق طويل للغايه يحتاج الى اراده
سوريه داخليه وايضا الى دعم عربي ما هي
الرساله التي يمكن ان ينتظرها الشرع
العربي الذي كان يتالم كثيرا لما يحدث في
سوريا من اجتماع الجامعه غدا هل سيحمل
قرارات ام انها ستظل امنيات
كما قلت لحضرتك
الكريم يعني فعلا هي مشكله معقده ولكن
يعني
التعقيد يحل بالتبسيط وبالتجزيء وبالتفكيك
ولذلك اليوم المطلوب تفكيك يعني المشكلات
السوريه وضع كل مشكله على جذب وحل هذه
المشكله مثلا لنبدا مثلا
بالمقاتلين الاجانب يجب ترحيل المقاتلين
الاجانب يجب تفكيك مثلا جبهه كما قال
زياده الوزير لا يمكن التعامل معها يعني
زعماء داعش قتلوا في ادلب ويعني صحيفه
نيويورك بانها عفوا
قالت بان ادلب اصبحت اكبر مقر للارهاب في
العالم لذلك لا يمكن اعتبار هؤلاء معارضه
مسلحه او انهم مثلا حمائم سلام لا يمكن
ابدا يعني لن تقبل اي دوله بان تطاوض من
حمل السلاح ضد ابناء جدته ومن يهدد يعني
تصوري هناك معامل كامله
للمخدرات المخدرات وخروج كامل عن سيطره
الدوله حتى المساعدات الانسانيه يعني
تقاتلوا بين بعضهم عليها هذه مشكله
الارهاب ومشكله المقاتلين الاجانب يعني
توضع على الطاوله امام قمه جامعه الدول
العربيه لديك احتلال تركي وتعرفين بان
الرئيس الاسد يعني وضع شخصا للحوار مع
تركيا وهو انسحاب القوات التركيه ايضا
لدينا احتلال امريكي ولدينا اعتداءات
اسرائيليه متكرره ولدينا نهر نهب للنقد
السوري كل هذا يعني مشاكل يعاني منها
المواطن السوري تصور لان يعني نحن نعاني
في دمشق العاصمه من نقص الوقود والولايات
المتحده كل يوم تسرق النفط امام اعين
السوريين اذا جئنا الى مشكله اللاجئين انا
اقول لك بان هذه المشكله تؤرق كل المواطن
اذا سمحت لي استاذ غسان قبل ان ننتقل الى
مساله اللاجئين هذه نقطه مهمه تعقيب بس
اذا كان هناك حديث عن الدور الامريكي
والتركي فهناك من يطرح ايضا فكره الدوري
الايراني في هذا الصراع الدور الروسي في
هذا الصراع او في هذه الازمه هل هناك
اراده حقيقيه سوريه يمكن ان تحيد هذه
القضيه الداخليه بعيدا عن كل هذه التدخلات
الاقليميه او الدوليه
يعني انا افهم من حضرتك انه كيف هو خطاب
الحكومه السوريه للشعب بشان الوجود الروسي
والوجود الايراني انا اقول لك يعني وبكل
صراحه لو لم تقد روسيا وايران الى جانب
سوريا لكانت اليوم سوريا مقسمه بين خبراء
داعش وامراء وامراء القاعده وكانت دمشق
محتله من هؤلاء اصحاب الرايات السوداء انا
اقول لك اليوم بان من لا مشكله مع ايران
ولا مشكله مع روسيا لان هناك اتفاقات تؤطر
يعني هذه العلاقه مع ايران ومع روسيا لكن
ليس هناك اتفاقات يعني الاحتلال الامريكي
هو احتلال موصوف يعني لم تبقى الولايات
المتحده هي دخلت بحجه داعش يعني على الرغم
يعني واكيد انت شاهدتي هذا المقطع من
الفيديو عندما قالت رام قال عن اداره
اوباما يعني هم الذين اسسوا داعش واتهم
يعني اداره اوباما وايضا وزير الخارجيه
بالنسبه للوجود الروسي انا اقول لك يعني
لان روسيا هي التي قضت على الكثير من
المجموعات الارهابيه ولذلك لا مشكله
اما عامل الاحتلال التركي الذي دخل
الاراضية عنوه لتحقيق اطماع عثمانيه يعني
هل سمعتي بالميثاق الملي مثلا
الميثاق الملي تصوري لاحظي الاحتلال
التركي من منطقه باني شمال اللاذقيه التي
تمسك بها باظافرها واسنانها تركيا حتى
الان لم تنسحب منها ومنطقه جسر الشغور في
ادلب وادلب وحمام عفوا وشمال حماه وعلى
الرقه الحسكه الى سليمانيه اربيل كركوك كل
هذه المناطق تعتبر اراضيا تركيه وعندما
دخل اردوغان سالوه لماذا يموت ابنائنا في
سوريا قال لانهم يريدون يستشهدون لاعاده
ارضنا هناك اطماع تركيه واضحه اليوم سمعتي
كان هناك مقابله للرئيس الاسد عندما جرى
قال لا احد في هذا العالم يثق باردوك وانا
اقول لك اليوم اذا فاز اردوغان ستكون
المفاوضات معقده وكبيره جدا وحتى مثلت
عوده عندما ياتي رئيس دوله مجاوره ويقول
لك انا ساعيد اللاجئين الى اين تعيدهم الى
مناطق اخرجت اهلها مثل العفرين ومناطق
اخرى
العديد من التفاصيل والتعديه ولكن اسمح لي
هناك بارقا
امل لدى العرب والشعب السوري اننا امام
قمه ربما تحمل الكثير من الطموحات
الايجابيه يعني صحيح اننا دخلنا في تفاصيل
وتعقيدات ولكننا لا نريد ان نترك هذا
الخيط من الامل
ان شاء الله يعني ان يكون هناك امل ولكن
انا اقول لك اللاجئ السوري يجب ان يعود
الى بيته الى قريته الى حيه هذه هي اعاده
اللاجئين ويترافق ذلك كما قالت
هذه السوري مع اعاده الاعمار وانا اعتقد
بان هذا هو المسار الصحيح وكل المشاكل تحل
اذا كانت هناك مياه صادقه من الدوله
السوريه ومن دول البيوت
هناك نوايا صادقه كما ذكرنا معالي الوزير
هذه المره لحتى هناك مصطلح بدا استخدامه
بشغلك بشكل كبير تصفير الازمات العربيه
محاوله خلق اجواء ايجابيه لان الانعكاسات
الاقتصاديه العالميه صعبه للغايه فالمواصل
العربي بالطبع يئن يعني تخفيف الحده هو
الهدف الرئيسي من هذه القمه التي ربما
حملت توافقا حول هذا الامر ما سمعت شو حكى
لكن بحكي لك شوفي الفرصه كبيره هسه احنا
صعوبه الطريق طول الطريق تعقيدات الازمه
هذا ما لازم يخلي في نوع من خليني اقول
التشاؤم بالقصه لانه ازمه بهذا الحجم 12
سنه بتعقيداتها فيها تفاصيل
لكن في لها مفاتيح هسا البدايه الاولى
مشينا فيها كويس البدايه الايجابيه
السوريين لما حضروا اجتماع عمان تعاملوا
بايجابيه مع الاجتماع وعلى البيان كان جزء
من البيان ومش فيه بكره خطاب الرئيس بشار
الاسد
لانه العالم العالم غير العرب العرب بدهم
يستمعوا ويشوفوا اللغه اللهجه المصطلح
النوايا يعني سيدرس جيدا ما الذي سيقول له
الرئيس السوري غدا وهذا مهم لانه اول خطاب
بعد المبادره وبعد الخطوه بالعالم هو راح
يكون جزء منه موجه للغرب ايضا لانه
الرسائل عم تحكي بالموضوع ورسائل العرب
اللي متحمسين للموضوع لكن القصه بعدين
بدها بدها خليني اقول اثمان اثمان بده
يقدمها العالم حتى لا يفكروا بعض بنحكي عن
شروط على سوريا فقط العالم بده يقدم انه
يرفع العقوبات يرفع يوقف المقاطعه الى
سوريا يفتح ايديس يعني يدعم سوريا ماليا
لاعاده الاعمال دعم نقوله ان هذه القمه
ربما المواطن العربي يشعر ان تمت شيء
ايجابي سيحدث
حقيقي وليست مجرد امنيات او احلام ولكن
الطريق طويل
وزير الاعلام الاردني الاسبق شكرا لك
تحياتي معالي الوزير وايضا الشكر موصول
لضيفنا العزيز استاذ غسان يوسف الكاتب
السياسيه من دمشق وخدمه العربيه الاخباريه
مستمره مع حضراتكم والان الى اخبار الساعه
وزميلتي ميسون نوح اليك ميسون بمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات